question à monsieur monsieur strauss
kahn vous venez d'entendre madame devant
les nouveaux trop téléspectatrice vous
êtes économiste
vous avez donc étudier un peu leur
comportement des ménages est aussi dans
le cas d'artisans ou de commerçants
comment ça se passe en général c'est ses
problèmes d'endettement
est-ce que c'est toujours aussi
dramatique que le cas de madame laval
par exemple votre auto sport je crois
que ç'a toujours aussi dramatique et
c'est vrai que l'histoire que la vienne
de raconter tout à fait dramatique ceci
dit le tonus qu'elles sont manifestés
fait espérer que assez rapidement elle
puisse arriver à sortir j'ai
l'impression que finalement
contrairement à ce que vous disiez il ya
trente secondes vous prenez ça c'est
bien
non madame tout à l'heure à
l'intervenant a dit quelque chose à mon
avis qui se raccroche tout à fait à ce
qu'on vient d'entendre
vous avez dit à propos du crédit
immobilier que vous aviez pris pour
votre maison mais ça c'est pas des
dettes parce qu'on le paye soit entendu
les dettes en fait c'est ce qu'on ne
peut pas payer etc les dettes chez
l'épicier par exemple ce que chez
l'épicier quand on ne paye pas un
épicier c'est parce qu'on ne veut pas
payer alors on traîne autant qu'on
pourra bon et c'est pas la même chose de
façon voilée présentée que la dette que
l'on contracte auprès d'une banque pour
acheter un bien immobilier parce que ça
en contact en sachant qu'on va payer en
ayant bien l'intention de le rembourser
selon un plan bien établi et ça rejoint
me semble-t-il mode situation parce que
si votre famille d'après ce que vous en
avez dit vous a si mal reçue à la suite
des dettes que vous avez contracté que
vous déplorez que vous pouviez pas payé
c'est pas parce que vous étiez endettés
c'est parce que vous ne pouviez pas à
les payer et donc le problème qui est en
cause avait pas de vivre avec des dettes
c'est de ne pas pouvoir rembourser les
dettes
et c'est là je crois que se situe la
façon dont corps social accepte ou
rejeter puis selon donc on était la
honte de la famille quoi puisque bon bah
c'est ça ça qui compte et mais c'est
différent de la position qui aurait pu
être de dire il ne faut pas s'endetter
je prends avoir compris que ce n'est pas
au moment où vous et votre mari vous
êtes endettés que vous avez eu des
difficultés familiales
mais après par soit considéré qu'il
était désolant de ne pas pouvoir
rembourser demain voilà c'est ça c'est
donc quelque chose de qui situe à un
niveau un peu différent et dominique
strauss kahn vous êtes économiste
sociologue est ce que on observe un
changement de mentalité face aux dettes
face au crédit face à l'argent que l'on
quitté de façon générale on n'observe
pas grand chose en cfa2 hypothèse
apparaît de quelques éléments qu'on a et
walsky
le fait que le calice développe
peut-être déjà dans leur mentalité qui
c'est vrai qu'il ya un changement et de
ce point de vue là comme sûre instant
que d'autres d'ailleurs les
comportements français ont tendance avec
un certain décalage à se calquer sur les
comportements qui sont généralement plus
développés ou plus anciens notamment aux
états unis parce que apparemment les
français sont beaucoup moins endettée
que les américains comme les allemands
oui alors les français sont beaucoup
moins endettée que américain lorsque
l'on considère le type de dette sur
lesquels nous avons plus discutés à
savoir les dettes qui concerne les biens
durables et biens de consommation est en
effet les français sont relativement peu
endettés là dessus la partie de la
consommation qui est financé en
s'endettant est relativement limitée
tout jeu télévisé heureuse de vivre et
ça pas très loin alors en revanche les
français sont honorablement endettés je
dirais en matière d'immobilier
et ça ça date du début des années 60
lorsque à la suite de des destructions
de la guerre et de la vétusté du parc
immobilier les pouvoirs publics ont mis
en place grand programme de
reconstruction on s'est aperçu sas par
les années 50 au sénat ce bout d'un
moment que il suffisait pas que
construisent appartement qui fait que
l'on puisse les acheter
alors du coup a été mis en place ce qui
n'existait pas en france au préalable ou
très peu une des formes de crédits aux
particuliers alors ça commence au début
des années 70 puis s'est monté très
rapidement et l'endettement immobilier
des ménages français est raisonnable pas
exagérer bresolin mal an pour ce qui est
des dettes en revanche qui concerne
l'achat de biens durables comme
l'automobile ou des réfrigérateurs et
hexa que les français sont beaucoup
moins embêtés car certains de nos
voisins
justement